Hello children, by now you must be
knowing that you
should practice sample papers, but
how will you practice sample papers? I have seen many times
that what some children do is that they will do
10 questions of sample paper in a day,
next 10 questions next.  You
can do it during the day but this is not the right way to do the sample paper. The
correct way to do the sample paper is
that you set a timer and do all the
questions exactly according to your board exams, that is, your paper would have been of 3 hours.  You have to do it
and it is not just that you have to do the
questions, it is only
after that you have to analyze
how you have written the things, so what you can gather is
that you should check it with a teacher or
even do peer learning.
You can do some sample papers, your
friends do some and you look at each other to see
how you have done.